ich befinde mich hier in einem fünf
Sterne Luxusresort mitten in Mexiko und
hier werde ich den ganzen Tag essen
worauf ich Lust habe von einem
gigantischen Frühstücksbuffet über 24
Stunden Room Service bis hin zu über
sechs Restaurants wo wir heute Abend
essen können lassen wir es uns
schmecken ah guten Morgen komm noch mal
rein mein lieber ihr könnt uns heute
einen Tag begleiten wie wir in unserem
Hotel hier in Mexiko einfach alles essen
worauf wir Lust haben und eine Sache ist
hier wirklich cool man hat ein kleines
Tablet im Hotelzimmer und wenn man dann
auf dining geht inro dining kann man
sich beispielsweise zum Frühstück eine
Vielzahl von Speisen bestellen und das
nicht alles denn man kriegt sie nicht
irgendwie geliefert sondern einfach in
diese kleine Box und ich habe mir eine
Kleinigkeit bestellt weil ich wollte
euch die ganze Bandbreite zeigen und
wenn man sich hier so fertig macht kann
man ja schon ein bisschen was für die
Vitamine tun wir haben einfach einmal
eine kleine fruchtplatte wirklich mit
der besten Ananas die ich je gegessen
habe und dazu verschiedene Säfte komm
Eric welchen willst du ich nehme mal
Pink Grapefruit ich nehme Standard
orange okay dann kriegst du orange
cheers das Ding ist nur weil dieses
Hotel so viel zu bieten hat kulinarisch
drehen wir überhaupt das Video weil es
fasziniert mich wirklich das ist doch
ein schöner Snack um in den Tag zu
starten werden wir sich ein bisschen
fertig machen und das Beste daran ist es
ja alles all inclusive don't have to pay
extra ich will euch das wirklich gerne
zeigen dass S jetzt nicht irgendwie so
blöd abgehoben kommen oder so wir waren
wirklich überrascht wie geil dieses
Hotel ist also wir hatten schon gedacht
das wird cool aber wie cool es wurde
unglaublich und deshalb zeigen wir euch
das sehen wir uns beim Frühstück dies
Hotelanlage in der wir sind wirklich
gigantisch groß aber guckt euch einfach
mal diesen view an den wir jeden Morgen
auf dem Weg zum Frühstück haben heute
ist das Wetter nicht so gut aber seht
selbst dieser view hier ist eh der
krasseste so kommt man ins Hotel rein
hier vorne ist der Eingang und man kommt
hier rein und hat einfach diese Aussicht
das ist wirklich einfach nur es ist
wirklich einfach ein Segen hier zu sein
das ist so schön wir sollenz warten wie
schön freue mich wirklich jeden Tag auf
jede Mahlzeit sowieso aber hier
besonders weil ihr müsst gleich einfach
mal die vielf sehen laufen gemeinsam
gleich einfach mal ein Buffet vorbei
hier gibt's wirklich alles thank
you dieses Frühstücksbuffet ist einfach
anders es gibt wirklich alles es gibt
frische Säfte eine unglaubliche Vielfalt
an Obst eine Avocado Toast Station eine
omelettstation mexikanische
Spezialitäten Frühstücksklassiker und
eine eigene süße Abteilung W French
Toast Donuts creb wirklich einfach alles
gibt was du dir vorstellen kannst und
das hier ist meine Ausbeute
ich habe es relativ traditionell
mexikanisch gehalten ein tamal ein in
einem Maisblatt gedämpften herzhaften
Reiskuchen nenne ich es einfach mal
warum weil ich muss jetzt hier nicht
jeden Morgen Rührei essen wenn ich schon
mal in Mexiko bin ich will es schon ein
bisschen mitnehmen dazu haben wir ein
Keser Taco oder eine kesadia ich weiß
gar nicht was der Unterschied ist sie
nennen das hier kesadia aber es ist ja
gefaltet wie ein Taco ein paar frische
TA
Chips eine Auswahl von verschiedenen
salzas und socen oh ich habe gesagt ich
ess nicht jeden Morgen rühere hab ich
mir doch ein spinatrüherei mitgenommen
weil das heute zum ersten Mal hier war
probieren wir
spinatrüherei
lecker und dann natürlich auch noch was
für den für den süßen Gaumen habe ich
auch Freude dran hier auf jeden Fall
nehme hier mal mein dal der ist gefüllt
mit chicken Guacamole drauf Salza werde
noch so eine schöne rote Soße das ist
nämlich das geile du kannst ja einfach
immer Freestyle alles zusammenstellen in
Mexiko Tamales esse ich hier wirklich
jeden Morgen einfach weil ich sie schon
mal selbst gemacht habe und weiß dass
das stundenlang dauert übelst undankbar
ist und hier kann ich sie mir einfach
nehmen und Essen schneiden wir mal die
kissadia an alleine dieser mexikanische
Käse den du in Deutschland überall
vergebens suchst dieser wahaka Käse im
Prinzip ist das eine Mexico foodour was
wir heute machen er du musst das
Probieren ich glaub das ist mein
Favorite bisher so reich im
Geschmack einfach wirklich immer dieser
dieser perfect bite den wir uns machen
bisschen eingelegte Zwiebel Pico de go
Guacamole probieren wir jetzt auch noch
die süße Station diese dicken belgischen
Waffeln wenn Waffeln in so einem Special
Waffeleisen gemacht sind schmecken mir
schon direkt doppelt so
gut was ist das hier
bitte wir genießen das Frühstück Eric
muss jetzt auch endlich was zum
Frühstücken holen dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder nicht zum Mittagessen
sondern zu dem kleinen Snack davor so
Freunde wir lagen jetzt ein bisschen am
Pool und das macht einfach Hunger wir
bestellen jetzt einen Cheeseburger und
das Besondere ist dass sie nicht einfach
gebraten werden sondern sie werden
gesmoked da ist er doch aber schaut euch
bitte einfach diesen Hamburger an also
ein wunderschön fluffiges Bann dazu
haben wir Crossen Bacon und eben dieses
ganz besondere gebraten gegrillt
gesmoked was auch immer Paty also die
haben einfach diesen Grill der krasse
Rauchentwicklung hat den machen sie zu
und dadurch räuchert das einfach so ein
bisschen beim Braten und das ist
wirklich sehr sehr lecker Stäbchen Weg
boah ist auch richtig schön heiß
Stäbchen Weg zeig ihn noch mal der sieht
wirklich einfach nur wunderschön aus er
sieht wirklich perfekt aus ne das ist so
ein so ein Foto das findest du wenn du
Hamburger googelst so Cheeseburger
googelst und diesen perfekten Bissen
gönne ich mir jetzt einfach geil was man
sagen muss ist jetzt zum zweiten mal so
das Fleisch ist wirklich well done
dadurch dass es durch diesen speziellen
bratrauchprozess gegart wird würde ich
normalerweise nicht bestellen aber ich
find es trotzdem unfassbar lecker wenn
man das sogar mag dann ist das
wahrscheinlich der beste Burger den du
jemals essen wirst wenn ich will könnte
ich mir noch 100 bestellen aber Teil mir
den lieber mit den das Mittagessen wird
gleich next level ein Stunde
volleyballzeit das heißt wir brauchen
eine kleine Stärkung wie sollen wir denn
sonst die Kraft haben Volleyball zu
spielen hab NS gegessen bisher heute
deshalb schauen wir mal was es hier so
gibt wo sind wir denn wir sind gerade im
seou Restaurant und wir hören die Klänge
von Live Musik hinter uns genießen die
frische briise und bestellen uns gleich
ein paar maritime
[Musik]
Köstlichkeiten das sieht doch toll
a geile Guacamole dann Fried Squid und
da drauf eine chipole Aioli auf einer
tostada also einem knusprig
ausgebackenen
tortier
wow wer es nicht kennt seafood gegard in
zitrussäure aber wir haben Yukatan Style
wir befinden uns hier ja gerade in Playa
del Caren das befindet sich auf der
Yucatan Halbinsel in Mexiko und in der
sevig haben wir Garnelen wir haben
Tintenfisch wir haben alles mögliche in
einem zitrussut und das möchte ich jetzt
probieren wunderschön frisch für einen
heißen Strandtag einfach
köstlich hier haben wir jetzt mein
chipolle shrimp also quasi noch mal
seafood probieren
wir sehr sehr geil sehr
geschmacksintensiv dazu gibt's so ein
Püree glaube aus
Bohnen mit diesem plaintain also mit
Kochbananen insgesamt verstehe ich
optisch sieht wahrscheinlich nicht
wunderschön aus es schmeckt aber sehr
sehr sehr sehr
lecker einfach geil oder auch mein
fischtaco den ich hier bestellt habe der
ja auch unnormal lecker aussieht wie ich
finde mit bisschen Kohl frittiertem
Fisch den ich jetzt auch mal probieren
[Musik]
muss ja jetzt werden Bälle geschmettert
spielen wir ein bisschen
Volleyball
Game Game
Game g das war doch was oder jetzt hat
man Sport betrieben jetzt kann man auch
wieder jetzt kann man wieder essen si
aus danke mein lieber hat sich
entsprechend gekleidet so wir müssen uns
jetzt ein Restaurant raussuchen hier
vorne ist schon das erste Restaurant
Nummer 1 dos Almas mexikanisches Essen
davon hatten wir heute genug Restaurant
Nummer 2 ber hier wird alles über dem
offenen Feuer gemacht also gegrillt aber
wirklich alles ist es glaube ich auch
nicht für heute als nächstes Suki hier
gibt es asiatisches Essen auch richtig
leckeres Sushi aber das hatten wir schon
ein paar mal gehen wir noch mal weiter
hinter uns ist jetzt das bizu das ein
französisches Restaurant dort gibt es
sogar beef Wellington besser gesagt BFF
und Krut so heißt das hier ist aber beef
Wellington hatten wir auch schon sehr
lecker aber in einem Restaurant waren
wir noch gar nicht es gibt ja auch das
seasou von heute Mittag das hat auch
jetzt heute Abend auf wir gehen aber
hier vorne ins italienische Restaurant
ins
wer seine Freunde nicht so begrüßt
einfach
dumm das also unser Platz hier für Abend
ein schöner Platz auf der Terrasse in
diesem wunderschönen italienischen
Restaurant ich bin gespannt wie gut
italienisches Essen in Mexiko
[Musik]
ist merk Italien Rela weit ist haben
diese schreckliche basilikumsße oh
wow starten wir mit demaco sehr dünn
geschnitten ja so das sogar schon reißt
wenn man es
aufgabelt sehr frische basilikumnote
frische basilikumnote schmeckt wie
selbst gemacht ganz
ähnlich darf man das sagen ich habe einß
Projekt von dem ich bisher ganz wenig
erzählt habe jetzt relativ am Ende von
dem Video exklusiv für diejenigen die
noch dran sind Pasta poesia wird das
Ganze heißen demnächst kommt ein großes
Video hier auf Youtube wo ich alles
erkläre aber eine Sache schon mal vorab
es geht um Pasta könnte man sich vom
Namen denken und diejenigen die sich im
Newsletter eintragen haben einen
früheren Zugang zum Produkt ist jetzt
ein bisschen kryptisch alles aber es
lohnt sich mal vorbeizuschauen
pastaapier ist unten verlinkt das wird
wirklich eine ganz große Nummer also bin
ich von überzeugt weil das was wir da
geschaffen haben ist next level ein
bisschen was habe ich auch schon auf
Instagram gepostet in res oder auch hier
auf Youtube Shorts deshalb schaut da
gerne mal vorbei falls ihr interessiert
seid bis dahin esse ich hier ein
bisschen Italienisch in Mexiko Insalata
Cab schmeckt so genau wie Tomate und
Mozzarella in Deutschland
schmecken und eine
brusketta nicht so knusprig
wahrscheinlich od ja mit artichockenherz
und oliventapenade aber nicht so
wirklich schön knusprig das ist ein
Minus aber es hätte mich auch wirklich
bisschen überrascht wenn das jetzt so
next level italienisches Essen hier
wäre ne das
Risotto Lasagne also ich möchte ja
nichts sagen aber mein sieht am besten
aus wir haben ein schönes Safran
Risotto auf jeden Fall eine schöne
safranfarbe
hat ein
schmorknochen schmorfleisch am Knochen
so rum aber schon vorher gezupft mit
schönen J boah sehr lecker probieren wir
mal die Lasagne ob sie auch schmeckt wie
am zweiten Tag sehr sehr lecker schöne
bchamel Note man merkt dass das eine
selbstgemachte Pasta ist ja ja ja mein
Gericht überzeugt mich auch wirklich
sehr also der ste könnte bisschen mehr
Biss haben aber ich glaub dass die
Mehrheit das einfach so gerne mag aber
mit dem
uguko und so oben drauf ist wirklich
unfassbar lecker und das irritiert mich
ein bisschen dass dieses Hotel sogar
italienisches Essen kann in Mexiko ich
denke aber dass wir noch was
nachbestellen B her können wir uns auch
noch K noch genug zu essen geben neben
gut zum Essen muss man aber eines sagen
hier hat man immer schöne Abende weil
der Service stimmt man kann bestellen
was man will ohne auf den Preis zu
achten man kann sich satt essen noch
viel schöner ist es ja wenn man die
richtigen Leute mit dabei hat
oder okay Freunde das ist jetzt ein
bisschen später hinter mir befindet sich
ein Taco Truck der jeden Abend bis 1 Uhr
nachts geöffnet hat ich habe mir noch
zwei Tacos gemacht einfach noch mal so
als kleinen Snack hinterher und danach
sage ich euch ganz ehrlich ist auch
wirklich Endstufe bei mir wirklich alles
gesehen was ich heute gegessen habe es
war viel deshalb noch mal die letzten
Tacos schmecken lassen ich habe noch
Besuch hier unten hier ist noch eine
kleine Freundin mit dabei will auch paar
Tacos aber probieren wir wie sollen
Tacos in Mexico schon schmecken ich
freue mich morgen das ganze noch ein
letztes Mal erleben zu dürfen bevor es
wieder zurück nach Deutschland geht aber
dann freue ich mich auch wieder auf
meine Küche Videos für euch zu machen
Weihnachtsmarkt alles was ansteht es war
eine wunderschöne Zeit schön dass ihr
ein bisschen Teil haben konntet bis zum
nächsten Video macht's gut haut rein
ciao ciao
ciao eine letzte Sache haben wir fast
vergessen ice cream Snacks und Kaffee
dieses Kaffee hat 24 Stunden auf hier
hast du jegliche Getränke hier hast du
feinstes Eis das reicht jetzt das war's
vom Video tschüss